la economía en directo américa de
france24 me acompaña en el estudio luis
méndez zúrich louis hoy nos vamos a
dedicar a hablar de las relaciones
comerciales entre colombia y venezuela y
empezamos con el deterioro así es raúl
ha sido un proceso progresivo durante
los últimos 20 22 años que parte de un
principio político en medidas por las
diferencias ideológicas de las posturas
de caracas y bogotá el 19 de agosto se
cumplieron 7 años del anuncio del
gobierno de venezuela de cerrar de
manera unilateral la frontera una acción
tomada por caracas en respuesta a la
presunta presencia de grupos irregulares
armados en territorio venezolano pero
más allá de este hecho el deterioro de
las relaciones comerciales entre ambos
países si bien tuvo su punto máximo con
el cierre de la frontera en el año 2015
ya venía en franco deterioro desde la
primera década del año 2000 cuando ambos
gobiernos intercambiaron acusaciones en
torno a diversos temas pero la situación
se tornó crítica en el año 2010 cuando
el entonces presidente venezolano hugo
chávez tomó la decisión de apartarse de
bogotá tras declaraciones del gobierno
de álvaro uribe donde denunciaba la
presencia de integrantes de las fuerzas
lunares de colombia farc y del eln en
territorio venezolano escuchemos la
respuesta con altura con argumentos que
nuestro embajador chaderton está dando
ahora a la nueva agresión del gobierno
de uribe un gobierno guerrerista
un gobierno que
cumple el rol que le asigna la extrema
derecha yanqui
ahí está el fondo del asunto yo solo
lamentablemente y esto a mí me duele
mucho porque colombia yo la llevo en el
corazón la oligarquía colombiana ha
jugado siempre a la división a la guerra
a la agresión recordemos cuando
agredieron al pueblo ecuatoriano y
repasemos ahora cómo han sido las
relaciones comerciales entre ambos
países a lo largo de los años pero lo
estamos hablando de países que comparten
2.219 kilómetros de frontera con
diversas topografías y posibilidades de
desarrollo a cada lado del área
limítrofe de acuerdo con el banco
interamericano de desarrollo venezuela y
colombia ostentan una relación comercial
de larga data pero esta fue
intensificándose en la década de 1970
hasta lograr su consolidación entre
finales de 1980 y mediados de 1990
porque pues porque colombia bien
venezuela un mercado plataforma es decir
enviaba a venezuela productos que eran
de difícil comercialización en el
exterior y hasta en cierta forma le
permitió dejar de lado el carácter de
mono exportador una situación que luego
se dimensionó
y derivó en un proceso de intercambio
mutuo que llevó a cabo programas de
complementación industrial que consistía
en que los países repartían producciones
en sectores estratégicos algo que quizás
se afectó un poco pero pudo mantenerse a
pesar del establecimiento de una zona de
libre comercio en 1994 donde junto a
venezuela y colombia se sumó méxico
ambas naciones así pudieron mantener un
buen intercambio comercial pero entre
1995 y 2013 este intercambio comercial
estuvo por debajo de los 1.000 millones
de dólares con muchos altibajos pero
tuvo su pico entre 2004 y 2009 con el
mayor dato en 2008 cuando alcanzó los 5
mil 117 millones de dólares hablemos de
cuando comenzó a louis el comienzo del
declive de las relaciones comerciales
entre los países raúl este tuvo su mayor
punto de inflexión en el año 2010 cuando
el intercambio comercial pasó de 3 mil
578 millones de dólares a mil 728
millones de dólares y entre 2010 y 2014
a pesar de que estuvo por encima de los
2.000 millones de dólares los peores
datos comenzaron a registrarse a partir
del año 2005 cuando se ubicó 352
millones y luego pasó en el año 2016 a
800 dos millones de dólares siguiendo
así hasta un poco más de 22 millones de
dólares en el primer semestre del año
de acuerdo a los datos suministrados por
el departamento administrativo nacional
de estadística de colombia pero el
cierre de fronteras en los años
siguientes generó una gran preocupación
especialmente en los comerciantes de la
zona que hacían vía vida apoyando a los
ciudadanos en ambos lados de la frontera
entonces louis digamos que fueron las
razones políticas las que afectaron
realmente este intercambio comercial
entre colombia y venezuela pero en un
primer momento sí pero también hay que
aclarar que más allá de la confrontación
política el comercio bilateral se vio
afectado por políticas económicas
impuestas en caracas que generaron daños
en el empresariado venezolano y derivó
en crisis de diversos sectores en ambos
países nos referimos específicamente al
control de cambio un mecanismo de
control de divisas que estableció el
gobierno de venezuela bajo el argumento
de proteger al país de la fuga de
capital esto llevó a los venezolanos oa
los importadores venezolanos a comprarle
las visas de estado que en ese entonces
a pesar con un barril de petróleo
elevado no tenía las suficientes divisas
para poder acceder a las demandas de los
importadores venezolanos una situación
que generó altas deudas entre este
sector y los exportadores colombianos y
esta expectativa tenemos respecto a esta
reapertura de las fronteras y como esto
además podría fortalecer el comercio
raúl por parte de ambos países han sido
ambiciosos en sus expectativas y eso lo
podemos ver en las primeras impresiones
del nombrado embajador de colombia en
venezuela armando benedetti quien indicó
que se espera un intercambio comercial
de 10 mil millones de dólares sin
embargo otros sectores especialmente las
cámaras de ambos países y también los
economistas advierten que este
intercambio podría estar entre 800 y
1200 millones de dólares para este 2022
pero eso sí se prevé un crecimiento
progresivo que podría alcanzar en el año
2036 los 4200 millones de dólares en
parte por las buenas condiciones que
está mostrando la economía venezolana en
los actuales momentos y la iniciativa
que ha contado con el respaldo de
diversos sectores escuchemos
tenemos la certeza que si trabajamos de
manera articulada nuestro impacto puede
ser mayor por ello damos la bienvenida a
esta iniciativas donde colombia y
venezuela le apuntan al fortalecimiento
sus territorios pero más importante al
desarrollo empresarial
por medio de acciones concretas en la
búsqueda de mecanismos innovadores para
impulsar mayores acercamientos para
finalizar que tenemos como cifra louis
hablando de esta relación
colombia-venezuela tenemos el superávit
comercial que tuvo colombia con
venezuela en los primeros dos meses del
año 2022 que rondó los 90 y 8.1 millones
entonces dijo ma siempre gracias por
toda la información económica y pasamos
a saludar a nuestra segunda invitada del
día